عقوبات غربيه متواصله على على ايران من
جهه ومن جهه اخرى باب ديبلوماسيه لا يزال
مفتوحه فلغم وصول العلاقات الى ادنى
مستوياتها مع قمع السلطات الايرانيه
للمتظاهرين والاعدامات وبيعها مسيرات
لموسكو الا ان خيارات الدول الغربيه
محدوده لمنع ايران من توسيع برنامجا
النووي ومحاوله انقاذ الاتفاق النووي
المواقع عام 2015 ليس هناك اي تفاؤل بان
فراشه قريبه وفق صحيفه
علما بان المحادثات النوويه توقفت منذ
سبتمبر الماضي حين رفضت ايران مسوده
اقتراح لاحياء الاتفاق غير ان مسؤولون
امريكيون واوروبيون يخشون مشاهدينا من ان
يؤدي وقف الديبلوماسيه النوويه الى منح
ايران انتصارا دعائيا اي تمكينها من القاء
اللون على الغرب الخشيه تمتد كذلك الى
اثاره ازمه اوسع من خلال انه جميع السبل
الدبلوماسيه مع طهران هنا مسؤولون امريكيه
كبيره اكد معرفه بلاده باتباع ايران مسار
ثابتا للتقدم ببرنامجها النووي لكنه لا
فتى ايضا الا ان التعامل مع المازق
الدبلوماسيه الحالي افضل بكثير من اي
بدائل اخرى وتشمل خيارات الاخرى السعي الى
صفقه محدوده اكثر او عمل عسكري او العوده
الى استراتيجيه الضغط الاقصى التي اتبعها
الرئيس الامريكي الاسبق دونالد ترامب
الاتفاق حاليا في حاله تجمل اي التزام
واشنطن وطهران بالوضع الراهن بلا اتفاق
ولا اسماء دون تجاوز اي خطوط حمراء قد
تؤدي لتصعيد وضع يصفه خبراء بغير